in the cowshed the man in charge of the
beef herd is at least a little bit hmm
he's a big fella am i right he's quite
bigger he's a 160 160 meter tall yeah if
I saw a man like that yeah but I
wouldn't get this close to him I don't
think I would think he was on steroids
or something I think he was a
bodybuilder it is 100% natural whereby
let's say within so many generation or
breeders have taken the best of the best
or the more muscle of the more muscle we
move from a numeral classical type of
animal and then we select that sort of
animal based on the double missile and
when you say double muscle do you mean
it has to of every muscle no no no
because it looks like it does it's not
exactly the same type of muscle than any
other grid except that in terms of
quantity each of these muscle is by far
more developed right
this cow is technically known as a
Belgian blue and it's the product of
selective breeding selective breeding is
the first stop on our tour of how man is
using science to control nature it's
used by farmers to enhance desirable
characteristics in their animals in fact
selective breeding is all about managing
sex to create these Belgian blues over a
hundred years farmers have only allowed
the cows and bulls for the greatest
muscle mass to mate and the result is a
bull that weighs over a ton the animals
breeders are keen to show off the
results of their hard work the Bulls are
shaved to best display their muscles in
order to highlight the the older muscle
so you can see where all the meat is
exactly but even here where they've sort
of trimmed in there yeah to highlight to
highlight that muscle has got a high
value you see and these are all gonna be
lean cuts and they're all for quick
cooking our babies right that's right
without you when you look at this you
you can't help thinking of lunch you
know is it helping the animal you mean
yeah what the animal is as healthy as
another intensive producing animal so
this is about the most technological
that we can get not the most
technological in terms of technology we
talk about selection natural selection
having achieved that
so what is the science behind the
Belgian blues there is a gene that
regulates the growth of muscles in
cattle these cows have been selectively
bred from animals that contain a copy of
this gene which doesn't work as a result
their muscles grow far larger than
normal to ensure that effective gene is
passed on sex for the Belgian blues has
been replaced by technology in the form
of artificial insemination he is a
basically a sperm machine either spur
machine
absolutely
it's very early in the morning for the
semen is now collected is in the
artificial vagina and from there we
process the semen in order to be able to
process artificial insemination on the
code so precise is the technology
involved they can analyze the semen
sperm by sperm to choose the ones they
want services this is testing the sperm
cam that is permanecer it's now checking
let's say the quality of the sperm we
have been collecting this morning Green
is good because you see that they are
very very mobile and they are looking
forward to to move towards the eggs and
these are not especially muscley sperm
don't you find that they are soft they
look impressive to me but I've never
seen visually you won't see any
difference there is no way to find any
difference between the bovine equine and
the the other species now right